yeah okay so okay okay okay I think we
got Shahadah guys so they're all on
board okay hello I'm just joking
actually Emily says that's okay you're
nearly there you're nearly there but you
need to cut down with the screaming so
you're needy that you're on the right
path so hey I thought Muslims are very
good at screaming I think that's ron
abboud
I shall
lady to high level things apart
well what's your name Flash Gordon Flash
Gordon flashing in flesh yeah like a
flash mercy flush okay you used about to
give me a card ya know what's it about
Jesus okay
does God cool a fool who does he call a
fool you he's like believing him dear
okay so I'm a fool for not believing him
that's right okay can we find out if I
believe any more you believe in him okay
okay um what did Jesus preach good stuff
a few examples that know regarding the
matter of a worshipping God what did he
preach worship him a lot worship Him
alone yeah yeah so jesus said worship
God a lot yeah okay yeah I did okay yeah
okay so um so God Jesus said worship got
to look yeah so do you believe Jesus is
God
yeah dude okay so Jesus came and said
hey you worship God a lot but you what
you did was he was like okay Jesus I
worship you a lot but he's got no no you
worship God he said he said he was all
like was all like right it goes he goes
yeah I'm Jesus yeah and I'm God's Son so
he sent me down save you me since yeah
well hold a second worship me salvation
is through me up there like a tesseract
let me get a maguet let me get this
right here Jesus came down and told you
to worship God then you're seeing that
he's God son but he's not God son
because he's good it's a bit confusing
right
it is that's why you look a bit confused
so other views yes because you just said
yourself you're confused right no I
never said that okay it's on it's on
camera so we know you said you've got
confused doesn't God say in the Bible
that God is I'm not a good of confusion
I don't know he does seem a bit confused
I'm not confused right you look confused
that's what big confuse if you have
Jesus in your heart okay but didn't you
just say confused right that's what he
did you just say confused yes I did but
you said I'm confused because you just
said y'all need food yeah yeah no so can
you explain why so confused I'm not
confused when Jesus came to the when
Israelites came to Jesus and said oh
good master
my what is the greatest commandment What
did he say love God no no he said hear o
Israel
meaning listener is rayul our God is the
best no our God is one
so Jesus said hear o Israel our Lord God
is one
why did you does not mention about the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
because well been invented yet
we haven't been invented yet okay so
they're going to be invented by Paul but
all so now you are preaching about Jesus
Jesus and you said that we I'm a fool of
a corner store yeah you said that I'm a
fool for not believing right but then
again you said you're confused you said
that the the matter of doctrine of the
Trinity was invented so touchy oh yeah
all right I'm going right God had not
yet come down to Jesus and said by the
way mate I'm the Holy Spirit as well
okay all right
did Jesus ever claim divinity no okay
let me get this right you said I'm a
fool he did what he died he did once it
was it so impacts that's thing so when I
invite a life so when God died he said
I'm blood all things so when God died he
said I'm good no he said father why have
you forsaken me well they saw it right
as he was a man and then I saw his
goodness and he came back right flash
flash first the rock listen listen I'm
gonna call you flash here cuz you know
Satan is flash yeah you're telling me
Jesus is God and he was on the cross and
he said father why have you forsaken me
yeah isn't it like that probably like
way more pain okay so okay so okay okay
you should be dead right yeah didn't
kill Roger so if he's good who is he
speaking who's the father his father you
look a bit confused he's God Alan teases
God is the father
I raised Jesus okay what's it what's it
what's with him he was screaming yeah
he's good yes yeah
who's he's calling out to himself yes so
he's saying help me okay I'm going to
help you is he speaking to himself no
because he's also a man he's a man and
he's God look okay if I see if I sit you
are more intelligent than us okay things
like that okay if I sit you I'm full
chicken and full man would you believe
me I have wings do you have wings
are you confused not really not as
confused as you I can't yet so how do
you believe that Jesus is God when he
didn't claim his self he never talked
about himself when it came with life
where we're giving out these cards you
need to know what you're talking about
as you know is all have sinned and come
short of the glory of God there is none
righteous no not one that's you that's
all you bastard okay to get to get us
that's all you nice people okay all
right that's better
and so to how would your sins be
forgiven you go to Jesus right you say I
accept your love what happened to what
happened to Jesus me what happened to
Jesus he dives we came back okay hey
he's around I'm still okay so in your
belief system god almighty knees blood
like a vampire no a lot like a vampire
on a second does he need blood
does he need blood to be from peyer's
right yeah they're like trying to be
Jesus but they're not as good okay does
God does the good that you worship
believe that there has to be blood
sacrifice no so why did Jesus died on
the cross then so can you tell me why
does God need blood was murdered
murdered so he didn't eat this was not
supposed to die he was supposed to bring
the truth and the light okay who killed
him the Jews who killed it buddy
probably right but be careful that so
basically you're saying that for you for
your sins to be forgiven you need a
blood sacrifice Lord in is connect trust
remind me yeah just calm down a bit yeah
I know you'll be excited today for in
Islam we have a belief system of nobody
needs to die we don't God doesn't say I
need an innocent man to die for the sins
of the world there's nothing like that
in Islam in its time but Almighty says
if you've sinned you repent and turn
back to me right so I just want to ask
you a question which one seems more
merciful in Islam we believe if an
individual is sin sins turn back to God
and ask for forgiveness in your belief
system god almighty see no I need an
innocent man and I need to kill him and
see blood then I'll be happy which was
warmer which was more merciful it is
which was one there are no innocent
which one's warmest you are a sinner
which was more merciful you are born of
a sir
I'm just all caught is merciful but he
sent Jesus to save us
okay he killed an innocent man sick man
okay he killed innocent then man sinned
and was not innocent anymore okay did he
kill Jesus no you killed Jesus roylene's
okay so the Grauman's killed God no look
you can son
okay so he's the son he's not good he's
both because when he the son of God have
you seen Hercules so he's got the powers
still okay so he's good good feel he's
good and he's the God of himself not the
God himself
okay everything he's Jesus God or the
Son of God he's both
how is he both oh he's the Savior but he
embodies man when he was on earth they
left earth and I was good again but if I
said to you I am full mammoth isn't just
like one person is everywhere okay but
if I the microphone I stretches in the
air okay so in fact if I said to you if
I say to you if I said I'm full human
being and I'm full chicken would you
believe me no why not because it is not
plausible you do not like that malicious
okay okay half delicious okay okay
you're kind of scaring me with your
comment so yeah so is that is that good
anything else you got to say to the
camera cuz this would be on YouTube I
think he so she loves books actually
okay why is that what's all that about
marrying a liar all that's Fox okay okay
can we talk about that yeah
okay so instead of swearing yeah we can
talk about that yeah you know a Virgin
Mary do you know how how much she was
machine Mary Joseph probably about five
and you know how well Joseph was for
about nine ninety ninety yeah so what do
you have to say for that [ __ ] it oh [ __ ]
that's all coming back to the 9 year old
what do we have to say about that then
if Joseph Mary oh look what is it okay
what about Joseph did Mary Mary when she
was five and he was no wonder
that's be a bloody Immaculate Conception
so how are you Christian when you go
against it
[ __ ] off okay interview age mine since
of Jesus and piss off way we're gonna
come to you I'm a bit busy
I promise my battery
yeah it's got nice and this is quite
interesting it's quite interesting yes
anyway sorry slow do you do you have a
Bible Bible on you know does anybody
ever borrowed this anybody on the Bible
okay flash trash-talker wife was alright
thank you thank you thank you for your
time
I'd appreciate for your time so I'm
going to drop to your level because
that's not it's understand teach me to
do that I'm not going to drop to your
level who's nice talking to you you do
seem a bit confused look we're going to
point YouTube we're going to put on
YouTube and let people decide for
themself so thank you very much
you
you